hello everyone and welcome to now
playing this i am i'm hosting this mario
kart live stream for some reason
and next to me is max holbert and then
we got mary kish
at the end who
uh he's not great at this game but we're
all learning we're all beginners except
for max and i who are professionals at
this point
uh but yeah this game comes out on
friday it's super good and we wanted to
show you just how good it is
by playing it very good
it's awesome that's how it goes
look a little dark up there
oh my god we look dark what's going on
with us
we're in the shadows
maybe they're maybe they're trying to be
polite about something oh no is it about
me keeping you in the dark whoa
it's probably something about me i
apologize i also apologize for being so
much on the shows today i was on the
lobby earlier ew
playing mario kart he does that i don't
know too much too much
samara have you played mario kart before
yes um but like it's been a while
so which mario kart have you played
um i probably played
what like gamecube or something okay
double bass back in the day a little dd
action yeah or what about you uh some ds
ah we used to have
carton call in the gamespot offices it's
probably the last time i played nice
and max the last time for you was like
64 except you played the hell out of
this game so i played a ton of 64 and
then i also had double dash okay um
i played the wii one but i didn't have a
wii so yeah
just for the best not to really play
though
getting wonked
i just
he's like just still a big iggy or
whatever
man every time i'm on a live stream it
goes there immediately
only the ones with you tom every single
time though
this is it's weird
oh
need to
rotate faster tom how was it
i want to know
oh now you're in a second excited
so this entire stream will be a
competition between tom and max well not
really ah jeez and me and warren will
try to duke it out
for
second to last oh no
was that you damn it that's the second
race in a row that you've done that
ah
okay now we get to watch our competition
shut up well this is the first time
we've ever like done these so when you
i'm adequate when you go off of a ramp
if you hit r
i don't know what button it is for work
the uh same as the sliding it's a
sliding button one for you
oh yeah so right when you yeah right
when you go off of bumps you got like a
speed boost why are we so dark it's
pretty dark
can we put some more light in here
it's pretty funny do you guys want to
watch the highlight reel anyone
i don't think the internet works yeah
come on james watch our highlights
you can't trust the monitor
don't try to see it
so i don't know any of the lines i'm
supposed to be taking no
it's not really fair forcing you guys to
play it like this whatever
are there lines i don't know i suppose
they're not sure
see there's one you missed
i guess it definitely helps to know
he tries to bite me what about
successfully do they
matter awesome yes the vehicles all have
different attributes but i mean you're
using the regular car they don't matter
right the regular cards because it's
well-rounded it's good standard card is
fine yeah
yeah you can choose you choose a cart
you choose your wheels and you choose
your hang glider glider
yeah that i don't notice like an
appreciable difference yeah a confusing
level
are you standard everything
seems to work
ah who hit me with a red shell
i don't know who it was they didn't pass
me
um
i got passed by morton i think morton's
my least favorite character
i had to choose
he's got a dumb star on his head
on his face yeah
or not ever
well there's a part where you have to be
in this level
damn it i keep falling off there but you
don't want to fall off okay falling off
isn't okay i figured it out
oh
warren what place are you in um
somewhere between 11th and 12th all
right
mostly
i'm hearing six
yeah it happens
it happened what did you do
i don't know do you even care do i need
carrots
dude
is that what you asked do you need a
carrot it's like a really sarcastic way
to get me more motivated
i know it's amazing i love it you like
learning from john steinbeck novels
topical oh no
who used the light a word
oh man i'm doing really bad
yeah it didn't fall off
i've been playing this game all wrong
what does that mean
i'm like yeah it's fun to be in the
water
did we ever explain where we are in the
thing so they've people they put us
there actually
we are in our correct spot
it's magic so that's why you'll see me
next to the number one for first all the
time i got seven
it's going going downhill how about we
go i don't know how slow i got learning
how to slide appropriately
that was bad for me yeah you use the
horn
yeah i got these
oh can i change vehicles this one is too
heavy yeah i think this was our last
race like this
oh you aren't using the standard car
you're using like an atv
i feel like it's really sluggish and my
driving skill sucks but it doesn't help
i also blame my car yeah that's a great
at all
sure
i think i think that was that i think
yeah we only did three i have a high
aptitude
and what
learning that's what aptitude is
for all learning
is trash talk you have to understand
do you speak a foreign language
i do now okay i guess i guess it's true
she's a hyper trap her trash talk trap
now you're thinking about what she's
saying it doesn't make sense and tom
you're with the french call
competitor what does that mean
what could that what does that mean max
i'm not i'm not falling into that
i don't like this
you know i don't speak french that's my
one weakness i'm in his head
he has no idea
do you guys want me to be i know that
there you should probably be like the
second row someone in there just like
one of the lighter kids creepy baby
like
and toe that and like they're kind of
well-rounded
light easy to control characters yeah so
they might be better for a beginner
standard
standard standing
all around
i'm going to use bowser's skin as my uh
it's my glider because you're mario it's
really yeah so you picked mario no one
takes mario and mario i know i it's so
it's so weird everybody's judging me now
okay so we're gonna do we're just doing
100 see if people are wondering
what was that you picked frantic mode
what does that mean that's probably a
lot of blue shells we're not doing that
good for us we're not doing that we're
doing a hundred seaters because you know
are you afraid tom
do you want to do 150c
i i thought i thought it would be easier
for you guys
it's on she she's i don't know why she's
trash talking it's awkward what am i
supposed to do
it's not it's not scale
the trick with the boost at the
beginning is to hold down the gas like
just after the tube
that is
the booster oh i shouldn't have wasted
that
do you have a coin did you waste your
time i i used that horn
oh whatever
well
probably never got a new blue shirt
yeah blue shells are super rare in this
game unlike the other mario karts in
which they're super annoying
so are you like happy or unhappy oh no
that's great that's great because this
game is way more about driving skill
which kind of sucks for you but it's
good for people i don't understand what
you mean by that i know it's tough
man you can't make that jump that we
just went through max it's in a hundred
seconds
i was going so fast did you throw
something backwards no
yes the third green shell
because it hit the green shell that was
coming straight for you really thrown
back i had thrown in a while ago oh
that's pretty funny but much
it oh man
how do you non underwater breathing
people
driving
logically this game makes no sense at
all i'll tell you that
i don't understand this course am i
allowed to go through the cupcakes or no
no
what are the cupcakes
it's one of the rides
underwater wow the the ground around
them is slow so if you have a boost go
between them because it's a shorter path
mushrooms are boost yeah but you need a
boost to make it
some of them no you could do it it's
just it's super slow yeah is that worn
again no
maybe that's all he has no it was me he
definitely
he's always giving himself a shocker
oh my god he never knows if he does it
either you've just forever changed mario
kart trash talking what is this oh what
is this
i have been in first for literally the
entire race
and now this jerk gets triple red at the
end
i thought you're saying that the items
have been
oh made fair slow down
yeah that was my fault
man
i hope you i hope you're proud of
yourself jerk head
i hope you're proud of yourself that's
mario
i just got a medal
the thing is like because the item like
if i would have gone to the right
instead of the left i would have gotten
hit and i would have won i know it's all
it's all we're going to watch the
highlight reel
cause that's the default option this is
what nintendo wants us to do oh yeah
right into the door look at how fun this
is there's koopa troopa uh writing and
then mary's yoshi my mouth is open and
you're all wet you're all you're all
moist it was a moist yoshi
uh there's a red shell that totally
screwed me over that's how i took the
lead
oh my god you almost hit me a second
time did you see how close i was i tried
but there's my green desperation shell
there that highlight reel is amazing
it's pretty short well you can change it
you can change it to your highlighter
you can edit your highlight reel and you
can go up to i don't know full you can
go to 60 seconds can you unlock it cut
out and take people out focus on
something make it all koopa
we're going to focus on metal mario
instead of uh mary no
focus on none
you're just gonna focus on middle mario
see what that'll mario was up to this
whole time wait let's see what wendy was
doing too
what
wait where where okay there we go
so wendy and metal mario for a minute so
you can see what this highlight reel is
there's wendy
it's pretty good it's a pretty good
start by wendy i'm going to crush her
oh i got touched he got touched by worn
and there's they'll get out
she's super intense oh look at that turn
that was a good turn
are you taking notes
mary cause she took a good turn there
about what her makeup skills or her oh
yes her makeup skills you don't you
don't have a bow either i should get a
bow we should get a big bow
jumps off a bangle
dsl
and some what nothing dsls
what are dsls
why am i the only one who doesn't know
now
saying it again won't help
i'm not gonna say it
she does
man i'm not going to
refute that
ah jeez
repeat what why don't you get reviewed
just look it up tom next
this happens every live stream
one of the ones that you're on
he learns more about the world i always
got to go to urban dictionary afterwards
to see what's going on go back to my
desk and i'll just like in 10 minutes
i'll just share this no
no
i didn't get the boost you're a little
late
get out of here windy
oh no
it's a gong mary but what noise does it
make gong dong
so for those rotating things do you want
to be on a certain one at a certain time
yeah i mean
because it rotates like clockwise count
like alternately so you don't want to be
going against the grain i see i see i
fell
also if you can line up with one of the
little
lips on on the end i'll give you a
freaking
little
jump boost off of it we're making things
very complicated
but yes you can make a jump boost
so if you hit
the glide at the top of a jump with a
slide button
then you do a little boost
oh no
losing it
oh
i went the wrong way run against the
grain
good job genius oh no
picking on the last place guy god
but you gotta play it
i don't know what to do in this part
which part you're just turning like a
club
then you go go against the or with the
grain if you wanted to boost up oh i see
the wheels yeah
the cog
someone's a jerk
is it me
uh probably not blue shell yeah i got it
what the hell tom what do i do three
wrench shells you know now you have one
thanks wendy i hit
always blamed for shelves
yes
this is this is an appropriate thing to
say during a nintendo game
so so when the when there's not bs items
at the end i totally win every time oh
well i chose i chose mario because he's
actually faster
horrible against the grain he's killing
me i'm taking the scenic route avoid the
i just want to watch it i just want
to see what else is here the dong the
dong avoid the dong avoid the tongue yes
it's good life of ice
you did it
finished i'm finished
it's all i'm hoping for
i wanna
get a medal
okay
well get a medal race better just do it
i don't want to get a participation
trophy like we're in
when you participate
i helped
one thing weird about this track
is that there are three laps right you
can see that in the bottom left corner
of each of our squares
but it doesn't actually loop around it's
just like i don't know three sections
checkpoints
yeah
we're always going downhill
it's so hard it's a metaphor for life
that's a metaphor for life
eat that banana tom
just gonna hang on to it
treat it like a friend it's not your
best confidant
how you drop your friends a man oh yeah
and his banana
are soon parted
deep very deep
uh
i don't know where i'm going
can you fly faster with the motion
yeah yeah
i don't think it was no it wasn't
he's learned her strength
oh i missed it
oh you got that poker
wow
is that also not appropriate
no that's okay for nintendo games
okay family friendly talk nintendo
man i mean you played you played this a
lot with me max you know that i came up
with murder you know i came up with some
pretty terrible swear you told me to
on my head
literally on your own head i think i
said that to max mcgee didn't i no that
was that was to me okay i think it looks
like it left a scar
i left at the sunny bunny really oh
thank you the sunny bona memorial part
of the track
oh god
who did this
did you get it no of course not i'm in
third
you're still in third
i don't know where to go
why do i have to turn my head when i'm
doing this
oh my god we're in feeding me
oh i missed the item box
yeah because skill won't do it for you
you need an item to do anything
it's called trash talk this is mario
kart tom do you get a boost if you go
through the circles yes yes you do i
don't think you're going to get a medal
though
no that's slow do you want a carrot
oh he's in your head
oh yeah i participated i got last enough
it's my first time losing
that was good i liked winning it could
have been
you won that yeah
wow generic statements oh look that was
my favorite one because i won
it was first in that one
i wish all the other ones were like that
one moving on
so what are the points add up to
who wins
so there has no significance
wait are we not who we think we are i'm
blue now wait a second go back
somebody go back everyone hit b
sorry
because we have to hit a in the right
order right so
now it's somebody else right what's the
b button on this controller
probably z
oh no that would be i don't know i don't
have no idea so we're now we're not in
the right spot yeah no you're gonna have
to switch again
i'm not yeah me and mary are not you
guys are gonna try this controller you
can trade controllers
i feel like i already have a learning
curve here
what do you what do you max you're
holding the controller wrong
sorry wait what am i doing then you're
fine max was holding it wrong pick a
crap player
uh
like no wait i don't know who i am
ah
has anyone been a baby yet no no me this
creepy baby
old babies are creepy
i've seen some babies are creepier than
others yeah and you're never allowed to
tell the parents no you can't be like
boy you got a creeping baby over there
they can tell by the responses because
some people say oh
who does he look like
some creeper
good for you big bag of me good for you
you made that all by yourself
good good for you oh this is the
rainbow road it's the new rainbow road
yeah no wait how do i go
go that one reverse
which is reverse you don't need to know
reverse there's no reverse come on
you serious just try to stay on what if
i need to go backwards you'll never need
to go backwards mario kart oh
oh guys who dropped the banana peel you
hit me first yeah is that you no i mean
i fell off rainbow road yeah immediately
it's a place where you go when you die
yeah but this is not that rainbow row
this is a weird one this is like mirror
is this a reading it's like a
russian this is like sputnik it's like a
1950s russian rainbow road
if russia had color
other than red
other than potato what color is this oh
it's potato oh damn it i fell i fell off
both roads i fell off a road i fell into
another road and then i fell off that
road the problem on rainbow road is you
can't use
any of your fancy googles if you have
any kind of sweet
mushrooms you're just going
to fall off there are certain stretches
i just i use three just now but it's
there's not many scratches you can
actually use them yeah like and i don't
know where they are so if i use them
i'll just die you will definitely die
darn it mario
did somebody just slap me
did somebody no no no no
yeah you were in 11th at that point
honestly it was gravity's fault
that's actually true
this track is pretty
it's so cruel it's pretty cool i mean it
is the last track in the game
and it is where you go when you die
it's random random you guys are jerks
i've fallen off every turn
oh shoot
shoot
rap after the shitty one wait after this
round or this track
okay
that sucks you're gonna you're gonna go
out winning nintendo says we can only
get 60 minutes of this so who's nintendo
yeah is that jan
is that what we're calling jan now
he makes the rules so we played it on
the lobby and then oh no i can't okay is
this not out here no come on friday
yeah it's awesome this game is taking
forever to come out i reviewed it like
on the 15th or something like that
rainbow road
yeah this was a tough way to end but it
also is a fit wait i mean it's a good
way to proper weight in it because it i
mean it's
oh my god i know
this actually keeps falling off hey if i
don't finish the race and i just go
really slow that means you don't have to
stop right we don't have to stop no we
also do
it isn't it
they made the worst rolls
and i'll just go really slow so
everybody can look at all these traffic
there you go doing this for you guys
let us not look at the replay
ever
that is terrible
i really do terrible no no don't fall
were you guys watching this
that was roy
mourinho
he almost fell there
don't fall
you don't get penalized as much when you
fall
they drop you back pretty quick pretty
fast
well
i'll tell you what i still feel
penalized
you beat warner
and no one else
it's not much of it
oh you got laughed there warren
yeah
well yeah he didn't laugh by mario just
for the users i want everybody because
i'm past
yeah i finished
okay that's it because nintendo said we
can't do any more you can't play anymore
so thanks for watching uh by i guess you
have to buy the system first we buy the
system in the game on friday right uh
because it's great thank you werner and
mary thanks for having me max holberts
and i'm atomic shay goodbye see you guys